Alterxona de baixa dosagem, né, o
chamado LDN, seria uma boa alternativa
para câncer de próstata. Então, LDN é
uma opção terapêutica promissora para o
tratamento e também prevenção de vários
cânceres, inclusive de próstata. E vou
aqui apresentar para vocês algumas
evidências desse elemento do LDN lowxone
pro tratamento do câncer de próstata.
Os estudos disponíveis mostram
resultados encorajadores do uso do LDN
nesse contexto de câncer de próstata.
Teve um estudo científico em que um
paciente com câncer de próstata tratado
com LDN, que é a sigla de natalxona de
baixa dosagem, vou usar essa sigla
agora, tá?
Nesse caso, ele apresentou uma
diminuição de mais de 20% no PSA, que é
o marcador que a gente usa mais para
acompanhar essa doença.
Isso em dois meses de tratamento. E após
6 meses, houve nova redução, sugerindo
que, pelo menos nesse caso, o LDN teve
um papel fundamental na estabilização da
progressão do câncer prostático. Então,
dados assim de relatos, né, em medicina
a gente chama isso de dados anóticos,
né, que parece piada, mas não é
anedótico no sentido de ser relatos. não
tão científicos. Então, esses dados
anedóticos indicam que todos os casos de
câncer de próstata que não haviam sido
submetido a tratamentos hormonais
entraram em remissão com uso de LDN. Eu
recomendo usar LDN isoladamente para
qualquer paciente, de maneira nenhuma.
Ele ajuda e na maioria dos pacientes não
é suficiente usar só isso, tá? Então o
LDN ele tem um potencial para prevenção
e tratamento precoce, sim, do câncer de
próstata e eu prescrevo para meus
pacientes. E quais são então os
mecanismos de ação anticâncer? Ele tem
basicamente sete mecanismos de ação
antitumoral. Aí vou falar um pouquinho
difícil agora, eu peço desculpa para
vocês, mas é rápido, tá?
bloqueio do eixo receptor do fator de
crescimento opio que é o OGF OGFR,
inibição da proliferação celular,
promoção da apoptose, que é a morte
celular programada através do
rebalanceamento da razão das moléculas
BX e BCl2, supressão da via P3K,
modulação das funções das células
imunológicas, ação antiinflamatória,
inibição de receptores TLR e redução da
produção de teleocina Pronto, parei de
falar falar difícil agora. Então, quais
são as dosagens e a maneira de
administrar?
Dosagem, você sabe que é crucial um
tratamento oncológico. Estudos
demonstram que o LDN, quando
administrado em baixa dose e de maneira
intermitente, pode prolongar a sobrevida
e promover a resolução das metástases
devido à ligação do fator de crescimento
opiódico que eu comentei, né, o OGF ao
receptor, causando uma administão,
então, desenvolvimento moral.
Encontrarxona
em altas doses contínuas, que seria uso
aí do Reva, que nós estamos não estamos
falando disso agora. Revia para outra
finalidade. Nesses casos, altas doses
poderiam acelerar a metástumal. Então, o
LDN tem sido estudado principalmente
como adjuvante, né, ou seja, como um
esquema adicional
em esquemas convencionais de
quimioterapia e imunoterapia por
demonstrar alto potencial anticâncer,
especialmente em tumores de origem
epitelial que expressam esse receptor
OGFR. Então, a evidência sugere que o
LDN pode sensibilizar células
cancerígenas resistentes ao tratamento
aplicado e permitir então uma
farmacoterapia mais efetiva com doses
menores de drogas citotóxicas.
E é importante ressaltar que
apesar do LDN ser muito promissor, ainda
tem necessidade de mais estudos
clínicos, que é um grande desafio,
porque é uma droga que perdeu patente.
Então, necessitaríamos de mais clínicos
em grandes grupos de pacientes para
poder confirmar a questão do LDN na
terapia do câncer. OK? Compartilhe os
vídeos, faça bem.
A vida de alguém pode mudar também no
canal do Dort além do Tr se volvar.